902 a.m. on April the 19th 1995 that's
the moment when 27 year-old Timothy
McVeigh exploded his way into the US
history books blowing up a gigantic
truck bomb outside the Alfred P murrah
Federal Building in Oklahoma City the
blast annihilated the building it ended
a hundred and sixty eight lives
including those of 19 children it also
sends a shock wave throughout the nation
no one could believe such an atrocity
was carried out by a fellow American
especially one whose normal seeming as
McVeigh yet McVeigh's callousness it
didn't spring from nowhere he was a
decorated war veteran a second Amendment
Crusader and a far-right activist more
than that he was a product of his time a
monster born from some of the most
controversial actions the federal
government has ever been involved in a
quiet loner a bullied kid he never fit
in McVeigh was the most average boy
imaginable and in the video today the
story of how that boy became America's
deadliest terrorist
[Music]
if you drive to upstate New York to the
town of Pendleton today you'll find a
small blue-collar community identical to
a million others across America
there's no historic marketer there's
nothing to commemorate the town that
gave birth to Timothy McVeigh born in
nearby Lockport on April the 23rd 1968
young Timothy was the middle child in a
household that was as boring as it was
dysfunctional his father Bill worked
endless shifts to support his family
while his mother Mickey divided time
between going on the road for work and
going on the road with other men years
later Tim would say that he and his
sisters Patty and Jennifer saw almost
nothing of their parents growing up not
that the children were isolated good
Catholics from Irish stock McVeigh's
were fixtures at the local church and
generally lived the sort of lives you
expect from small town nobodies when
Mickey finally left in 1978 and took
Patsy and Jennifer to live in Florida it
was just another chapter in that
American classic the great big book of
suburban misery the 10 year old Tim
being left alone with dad bill
effectively meant being left entirely
alone there was nothing to do in
Pendleton and nobody to do it with
especially not when you were a lanky
intelligence and painfully shy boy that
nobody seemed to understand the only
person Tim really connected to in those
days was his grandpa the two would go
shooting together a rare escape from the
beatings that Timothy received at school
as he entered his teenage years the boy
mockingly called noodle by his
classmates began to develop a vague
paranoia that the government might come
and take his beloved guns away depriving
him of this one last escape from his
miserable life it was a feeling that he
found reflected in the Turner Diaries
now if you've never heard of the Turner
Diaries you're probably going to have a
fairly miserable next 30 seconds they
were written by a neo-nazi called
william luther pierce in 1978 and the
book features a white uprising against
the Jews and blacks who are controlling
America and it culminates in the whites
committing a justified genocide in short
the Diaries is as a textbook a
definition of racism as you're ever
likely to find the sort of book Hitler
would gobble up for his Nazi breakfast
yet it also contains perhaps the key to
McVeigh's actions in one passage the
heroes detonate a crack bomb outside a
federal building killing 800 people for
14 year-old Timothy reading the Turner
Diaries was like someone had opened his
eyes Pierce's book tapped into the deep
paranoia the young boy was already
feeling he became a sort of teenage
survivalist stockpiling food for a
nuclear war that was never Cummins
ramping up his defenses of the Second
Amendment plenty of teenagers though
they go through phases of extremist
belief only to later turn into
completely normal adults and this is
something that almost happened to
Timothy something of a computer whiz he
graduated high school in 1986 with a
partial scholarship at this point the
boy's life it could have taken a
permanent turn for the ordinary but it
didn't for whatever reason Timothy
dropped out after two years of bumming
around Pendleton he made the decision
that would change his life and the lives
of a hundred and sixty-eight people
living in Oklahoma City forever he
decided to join the army
[Music]
IRA's spring of 1988 when McVeigh
graduated from boot camp and became a
paid member of the US military by all
accounts he was a model soldier he even
managed to make real friends for perhaps
the first time in his life pairing up
with two guys called Michael Fortier and
Terry Nichols like McVeigh Nichols was a
guy from Nowheresville with an absent
father like a McVeigh Nichols was a
second Amendment advocate with a
creeping distrust of the government and
like McVeigh Nichols would soon choose
to express that distrust through
horrific violence but before we get into
that we first got to take a quick trip
to the Arabian desert August the 2nd
1990 and Saddam Hussein's army rolls
into Kuwait leaving a trail of horror in
its wake
ordinary courageous are abducted off the
streets tortured to death and their
bodies and dumped on their family's
lawns over 400,000 people flee the
country faced with a humanitarian
catastrophe George HW Bush orders the US
Army to Kuwait's borders along with them
is Timothy McVeigh now a special gunner
McVeigh was at the head of a column that
rolled into occupied Kuwait on January
the 17th 1991 he witnessed the fierce
fighting and the collapse of the Iraqi
army firsthand
indeed he fired one of the list shots of
the war as his column moved into the
desert McVeigh pulled the trigger on a
cannon shot that blew and Iraqi soldiers
head clean off although he celebrated at
the time he later told his official
biographers that the image of the man's
upper body disappearing in a spray of
red mist it came to haunt him as his
platoon marched north along dusty
highways littered with burns our
wreckages of destroyed Iraqi vehicles
his celebration it gave way to horror by
the time the war ended on February the
28th something inside because they had
gone out some vital spark of empathy had
gone and it was never to be rekindled
the next few months were rough for the
decorated soldier utterly exhausted by
the Gulf War mcsatchle UNG's the Army
Special Forces training after two days
he took an honorable discharge and
returned to Pendleton where he failed to
find steady work traumatized and
directionless he returns to his one real
love guns in 1991 the gun show circuit
was a place of itinerant Wanderers for
Nat
and enthusiasts who lived a nomadic
existence roaming the empty plains of
America and Hawking their wares McVeigh
joins their number of logging copies of
his childhood favorites the Turner
Diaries to a receptive anti-government
audience at some point he made contact
again with Terry Nichols who'd left the
Army on a hardship discharge before the
Gulf War the two went into business
selling army surplus as they spends more
and more time together they had fuel
into the fire of one another's
resentment of the government but it
would be two major events that would
turn those smoldering embers into
apocalyptic wildfires
at the same time Timothy McVeigh was
becoming desensitized to violence in the
Arabian desert an anonymous man named
Randy Weaver was missing his Idaho court
date a former Green Beret Weaver had
taken his wife Vicky and their children
and retreated into a tiny survivalist
cabin overlooking Reedy Creek in 1989
ATF agents tried to turn him into an
informer when Weaver refused he was
indicted on firearms offenses in
February 1991 he failed to show up at
his trial and an arrest warrant was
issued on August the 21st 1992 US
Marshals finally tracked Weaver to his
cabin as they approached Weaver's dog
Stryker started barking 14 year old
Sammy Weaver came out of the cabin
running with his gun in hands
what exactly happened next no one knows
what we do know is that when the dust
cleared striker Sammy and deputy marshal
Bill Deegan they were all dead
the FBI laid siege to the cabin on
August the 22nd FBI sniper lon hurry you
cheese shot Randy as he tried to check
on Sammy's body
Randy ran for safety and hurry you chief
fired again this time his shot missed
the wounded Randy as Vicky Weaver
stepped up to the doorway her newborn
child in her arms
the bullets struck her through her head
and she died instantly the deaths of
Sammy and Vicky Weaver were like a
lightning bolt to the heart of the gun
circuit for McVeigh and Nichols and
others like them Ruby Ridge was proof
that the government was coming for your
guns and that kill your entire family in
order to get them it was in the shadow
of this tragedy that an even greater and
even more controversial tragedy occurred
and you'll certainly recognize the name
of this one because it was Waco On
February the 28th 1993 ATF agents raided
the Branch Davidians religious compound
outside of Waco after David Koresh was
accused of violating firearms
regulations and if you do want to learn
more about David Koresh do check out our
video about him I'm gonna link to it in
the description below
now that rage it turned into a massacre
that killed four ATF agents and six
davidians the massacre then turned into
a standoff before transforming into a
siege when the FBI got involved for the
next 51 days the world watched as Waco
became a circus the firearms angle drew
in protesters from across the country
and among them was Timothy McVeigh
McVeigh joins the crowd of journalists
protesters and rubber necker's on a hill
three miles from the comp
watching as all the action unfolded he
hawks anti-government bumper stickers
and like many others predicted another
Ruby Ridge
however he wouldn't be there to see
quite how right he was on April the 19th
the FBI tried to storm the compound
instead to the world watched in horror
as it went up in flames billowing black
smoke filled the sky hanging in a
poisonous cloud above Texas to this day
there is still debate over who started
the fire but there's no debate over the
outcome the charred corpses of 75
Davidians were eventually pulled from
the rubble among them 25 children look
they watched the Davidians burn live on
TV from Nichols's couch on his farm in
michigan exactly what he felt seeing his
darkest fears realized is of course
unknown but we do know that in the
aftermath McVeigh and Nichols began
experimenting with building pipe bombs
their anger at the government had
reached a boiling point and the two men
began their slow slide toward extremism
and of course committing horrifying
vengeance
in September of 1994 President Bill
Clinton signed into law the assault
weapons ban briefly outlawing certain
types of firearms coming in the wake of
really Ridge in Waco the ban was like
tossing gasoline onto the fire of
anti-government propaganda
McVeigh would later claim that this was
the last straw
initially the young extremists he hoped
to assassinate prominent figures in the
federal government among his targets
were Attorney General Janet Reno and lon
her EOD the FBI sniper who'd killed
Vicki Weaver at Ruby Ridge but this
planet soon fizzled getting past
bodyguards was too tricky and there was
no guarantee McVeigh would be able to
assassinate even a single figure before
being caught
instead she turns to an unlikely source
of inspiration Islamic fundamentalism
the year before just three days before
the Waco Siege a small Islamist cell had
exploded a truck bomb beneath the World
Trade Center the blast had been intended
to collapse the North Tower killing
hundreds of people in the end though it
failed to damage the foundations and
killed only six people for macfay the
1993 WTC bombing was a source of both
inspiration and contempt while he was
impressed that such a small cell had
managed to attack such a high-profile
landmark he considered their attack of
failure in later years he admitted to
studying for bombing obsessively and he
vowed that he could do better his first
step was to get Terry Nichols involved
richer than McVeigh and with more
practical knowledge and explosives
Nichols was necessary for the success of
any attack so in late September McVeigh
took him to one side and explained his
plan together the two of them were going
to blow up a federal building just like
in the Turner Diaries in a happier world
Nichols would have responded by saying
yeah shorten and then immediately
alerting the FBI but this isn't a
happier world the feds they were the
enemy and Nichols was just as angry and
just as ready to lash out at the
government as McVeigh was so when
McVeigh said let's build a bomb Nichols
he simply said well yeah throughout
September the pair slowly began amassing
bags fertilizer when they weren't buying
they were hanging out with their old
buddy Michael for tea errands setting
off pipe bombs and in secluded canyons
by October McVeigh
made a connection who promised to sell
them nitromethane a highly potent racing
fuel on October the 20th of the pair
drove to Dallas Texas to pick up a batch
on the way they stopped in Oklahoma City
today a controversy remains over the
point of which McVeigh decided to bomb
the Alfred P murrah Federal Building
some believe the decision was taken in
September others believe that wasn't
until the morning of the bombing when
the original target had to be scrapped
at the last minute
whatever the truth the FBI's official
chronology of McVeigh's movements in the
fall of 1994 states that here nichols
pulled over outside the mara building on
their way to dallas long after he was
arrested
McVeigh would say had originally chosen
another Federal Building in the city but
had a change of heart when he noticed it
housed a flower store evidently he felt
no such reluctance when he saw the
Murrah buildings daycare center it was
during the Dallas trip that McVeigh got
some unfortunate news his grandfather
had passed away following a long illness
the man who'd once been young Timothy's
only friend was now gone and with that
McVeigh his last connection to the world
was severed the next few months unfolded
in a haze of petty crimes of fertilizer
stockpiling and mind-numbing normalcy
McVeigh visited gun shows tried to hook
up with women and even took a vacation
this below this average bustle of life
something much darker was beginning to
take shape
Nichols by now was stealing guns to
generate funding and the two were slowly
filling countless drums with fertilizer
and with fuel as a 1994 ticked over into
1995 McVeigh was making more and more
trips to Oklahoma City at least once
with Fort here in tow away from his
future target though he was starting to
dabble in crystal meth and acid as the
winter slipped away into spring McVeigh
he cut himself off from everyone even
Nichols by April he was spending long
night sleeping in his car and lying low
in motels at some point Fortius wife
made him a fake ID to use for renting
vehicles McKay's last week as a free man
is still shrouded in mystery he rented a
hotel room in Junction City Kansas and
may have been spotted conversing with
still unidentified men at some point a
man known as John Doe - allegedly rented
the Ryder truck used in the blast
eyewitness accounts of dough to fuel
conspiracy theories about the bombing
to this very day as Easter Sunday 1995
arrived nickels finally traveled down to
Kansas on April the 18th e'en McVeigh
drove out to Geary Lake with their
fertilizer and their fuel as the Sun
came up over the water they mixed their
ingredients together creating a highly
unstable bomb by noon they were done
McVeigh said goodbye got back in the
Ryder truck and drove off into the
bright spring afternoon the next time
Nichols heard his old friend's name with
the infamous
[Music]
on April the 19th 1995 state trooper
Charlie hanger was out patrolling the
empty highways north of Oklahoma City
when he spotted a car driving without
plate it had been a heavy morning
hangout just heard on the radio that
some kind of explosion had happened in
Oklahoma City and all the cops in the
area were converging on the disaster but
hanger was nothing if not by the book so
rather than turn his car around and
screamed towards the smoke-filled
skyline he flicked on his lights and
pulled over the battered old plateless
Mercury a gaunt young man was sat in the
driver's seat common expression on his
face as hang her asked to see his
license he noticed a bulge under the
young man's jacket he was carrying an
illegal concealed weapon young man
followed hangers.i aligned and gave her
tight grin my gun is loaded officer he
said so is mine
replied hanger yanking his pistol out
and pointing it at the young man's head
as hanger drove his prisoner back
towards Perry and the local County
Courthouse he was passed by more vehicle
speeding towards Oklahoma City it never
even occurred to him that he might have
the bomber sat in his backseat the
Oklahoma City bomb had exploded at 9:02
a.m. in front of the Mara building the
blast had removed the north wing and
collapsed all nine floors windows 25
miles away had shaken from the shock
wave in the aftermath ordinary
Oklahomans had watched in horror as the
bloodied corpses of children were pulled
from the rubble
all told 168 lives had been snuffed out
as news spread so did the suspicion that
a foreign power was involved the bomb
was simply too powerful the media
broadcast stories about Arab terrorists
attacking the heartlands grave-looking
spokespeople came on TV and said there
was a possibility Saddam Hussein had
actually orchestrated the attack in
Perry Courthouse Timothy McVeigh calmly
watched these reports unfold at that
moment he was the most wanted man on the
planet and no one had the faintest
inkling that he was already in jail on
Friday morning two days after the
bombing McVeigh was about to go and see
the judge and post bail when a frantic
FBI operator called Charlie hanger to
ask if this traffic violation guy was
still sitting in the cells hanger said
well sure keep him there
the operator barked whatever you do do
not let him go by fluke the Ryder trucks
axle
destroyed in the blast held two blocks
through the air it had been recovered
with its serial number still intact
the FBI managed to trace it back to a
motel where McVeigh had stayed using his
real name and with that the game was up
in Perry a mob of angry Oklahomans
surrounded the courthouse as federal
agents arrested McVeigh chants of baby
killer filled the air as he was dragged
out into the media spotlight McVeigh
seemed totally unfazed by the attention
he simply scans the nearby rooftops his
eyes flitting from one to the other with
an eerie calm McVeigh would later say
that he was sure an FBI sniper was about
to take him out as they had with Vicki
Weaver three years earlier that would be
bad because he didn't want to die until
he told his story until they'd explained
why he had done it it was sure that when
the American people heard his reasoning
they would rise up against the
government just like in the Turner
Diaries Timothy McVeigh was indicted on
August the 10th 1995 Terry Nichols had
surrendered to authorities the day that
McVeigh was identified and was charged
as a co-conspirator Michael Fortier was
also arrested and turned star witness in
return for a lenient sentence of the
three men only Fortier would ever taste
freedom again
in the end the trial of Timothy McVeigh
took one month
McVeigh instructed his lawyers to use a
necessity defense arguing that he was in
immediate danger from the government and
the bombing was an act of self-defense
but his lawyers they refused at the end
of the trial the jury unanimously
recommended death by lethal injection
Terry Nichols was sentenced to a hundred
and sixty-one consecutive life sentences
with no possibility of parole
following McVeigh's conviction jubilant
Oklahomans paid to fly the jury out to
Oklahoma City and gave them a VIP tour
for a brief period after his trial
McVeigh was incarcerated in ADX Florence
Colorado in a wing known as Bombers row
a real-life Arkham Asylum Bombers row
was already home to Unabomber Ted
Kaczynski and WTC bomber Ramsey Ahmed
Yousef according to one of mcveigh's
biographers he and Kaczynski became firm
friends bonding for a love of nature
Yousef meanwhile tried to convert the
Creator Islam but McVeigh politely
declined McVeigh never expressed any
remorse for his actions and in his
biography he called the 19 dead children
collateral damage he maintains that the
bombing was a justified response to Waco
and he wasn't alone the great writer
gore Vidal became a pen pal of McVeigh's
and spent the last years of his life
ultimately defending mcveigh's actions
at one point comparing him to an
American Hero Paul Revere and suggesting
that he was really innocent
Paul McVeigh respected for all he had no
truck with theories that had been framed
he had carried out the bombing and he
wanted everyone to know it McVeigh was
finally executed on July the 11th 2001
the day he was put to death so many
natives of Oklahoma City wanted to watch
the monster die that a lottery system
had to be set up to ration places in the
chamber the rest watched via satellite
link from the very city McVeigh had
callously torn the heart out of only six
years before at 7:15 a.m. Timothy
McVeigh became the first federal
prisoner to be executed since 1963 as a
cocktail of lethal drugs was slowly
pumped into his system he refused to say
a word with eerie calm he simply looked
into the camera broadcasting his death
Dhokla him a city forcing his eyes to
stay open even as his heart slowed to a
stop when he finally died his eyes
remained fixed on the camera as if
mocking those that it hurt so much at
the moment we've made
he was the mastermind of the deadliest
attack in US history
he was the boy next door who'd read a
book and dared to turn its plot into a
horrifying reality as his heart stopped
it was on a world in which Americans
still feared the government's and
right-wing terror was the biggest
concern of law enforcement it was a
world that McVeigh had helped to create
but it wasn't one that would last
exactly three months after McVeigh
breathed his last Islamic fundamentalist
smashed planes into the Twin Towers and
the Pentagon killing 17 times as many as
McVeigh had in the aftermath of 9/11
support for the government surged to its
highest level in decades right-wing
terror vanished from the headlines
replaced by the specter of Islamic
extremism in the wake of nearly 3,000
dead in New York City the bombing of the
Murrah Building was almost forgotten yet
McVeigh still holds a special place in
American history no domestic terrorist
has ever equals the horrific acts that
he carried out their day an act which
inspired everyone from the Columbine
killers to Anders Breivik even today he
casts a long boys Enosh shadow once
again anti-government further is on the
rise far-right extremists like Dylan
roof and Pittsburgh shooter Robert
Bowers are sowing terror in American
communities as the world lurches back
towards the darker place it's worth
remembering the life of Timothy McVeigh
and the lessons that his awful crime
taught us all so I hope you found that
video interesting if you did please do
hit that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe we've got
brand new videos just like this twice a
week so hit that subscribe button and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]
you